कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में के
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
मेरी फेवरेट कंफर्ट्स सीखने वाले हैं वाइट
टाइगर कनेक्ट हैं अभी यह मेरी फेवरेट
कंसेप्ट क्यों है कि जितनी इजी है उतनी वह
इंपोर्टेंट है बहुत ही इजी है ना हम आज
कुछ सेंटेंस का आयोजन करने वाले हैं ना
कुछ करने वाले हैं और इंपोर्टेंट इसलिए है
कि इनका यूज करने के बाद आपकी लैंग्वेज से
नेक्स्ट लेवल की दिखने लगती है क्योंकि हम
भी वन पर है तो यस जितना ग्रामर
इंपोर्टेंट है उतना यह दिखाना कि हमारी
लैंग्वेज में हम थोड़ा आगे लेवल का बोल
सकते हैं वह भी इंपोर्टेंट है तो फॉर
एग्जामपल कि हिंदी में देखो मैं चाय और
कॉफी पीता हूं नॉर्मल लगता है मैं ना
सिर्फ चाय पर कॉफी पीता हूं
को एकदम हाई लेवल लगता है इंग्लिश में
हाईट ड्रिंक पीएम कॉफी उसका अगर आप करोगे
आयोडीन क्वालिटी बट अलसो कॉफी एकदम
नेक्स्ट लेवल लगता है तो आसफ ऐसे ही एकदम
सिंपल कनेक्टर से रफ कंपलेक्स सेंटेंसेस
फ्रॉम हाई लेवल के क सेंटेंस बनाना सीखने
वाले हैं तो यह वाइट हेलीकॉप्टर है क्या
तो यह दोस्त सेंटेंस सेंटेंस के पास
जोड़ते हैं
है और वह जो सिंपल पांच जो है वह काम
सीखने वाले है पहले मैं आपको 15 कि सिर्फ
एक लिस्ट देता हूं और फिर हर एक हम इन
डिटेल सीखने वाले हैं तो पहले देखो कौन सा
है निशान ऑर्डर नऊ कैन नॉट ओनली बट अलसो
इन इंग्लिश दूसरा है Twitter करंट अफेयर
और तीसरा है वह टर्नऑफ उससे उल्टा इधर न
सोता है इस वाइर यह थोड़ा अब इसका इंटरफेस
ऑल दो बट पर पांचवा है - जॉइंट अंदर सेट
एक तरफ़ वो दूसरी तरफ और वन हैंड अंदर है
तो अभी यह पांच का यूज करके हम एकदम ऐसे
नेशनल सेंटेंस बनाना सीखते हैं तो सबसे
पहले सबसे सिंपल निशान और जॉर्डन आऊंगी
मतलब नॉट ओनली बट अलसो इस मैंने बोला था
ना कि मैं ना सिर्फ चाहे पर कॉपी भी की था
मगर ऐसा आपको बोलना है इंग्लिश में क्या
बोलेंगे आई डोंट ड्रिंक नॉट ओनली थे
एंग्री बर्ड्स ऑफिस जर्मन में क्या होगा
स्प्रिंकल मिसनोमर टैग्स ऑन द रॉक प्ले
सॉइल है कुछ भी नहीं है सिंपल सेंटेंस
स्ट्रक्चर सेमी रख इस ग्रीन अधीक्षक व
टैग्ड अनोखा ट्विस्ट सिमिलरली आईएफ ठे नॉट
ओनली क्रिकेट बटन सॉफ्टबॉल इस पिलर इन
आंवलों अ क्रिकेट जॉन्डर आउट पुष्पा एकदम
सिंपल साइड में ऐसे ही अगर आप इधर और करना
है तो क्या करोगे एंड टि्वटर ऑर्डर इन
ट्विटर यूजर लॉगइन आइडलेट्री और कॉपी मैयत
चाय पीता हूं कविता तो क्या होगा जर्मन
में स्प्रिंग कयना Twitter The Amazing
कपड़े
ए सिंपल बट सिर्फ अपने ट्रैक्टर लगाएगा आप
देखोगे तो वैसे ही आई प्ले आई जब क्रिकेट
और फुटबाल इस पिलर एंड वेटरन क्रिकेट
आर्डर उस वक्त इधर सिंपल उसका होल्डर नजर
और इंग्लिश में यहां पर वेटर नॉक आई डोंट
ड्रिंक नाइजर t9 कॉफी इस ट्रिक वेयर टैग्ड
नोक पे
कि आई प्लेन उधर क्रिकेट और फुटबाल
स्पीलवे यह क्रिकेट नोआखली बहुत सिंपल कुछ
भी नाम इन ए सेंटेंस में कुछ चेंज किया है
कुछ भी नहीं किया हमने सिर्फ छह वर्ड
सिखाए अंदर से अभिशप्त फॉर प्रॉपर और
मिनट्स अंदर साइड से वह ही सिंपल है पर
उसमें जैसा प्लेटफार्म की जड़ जैसे जो
सवार है और अंदर से इसको अंदर सेक्स है उस
सेंटेंस का पाठ बनते हैं जो मैं लास्ट
टाइम देखा था तो फिर प्रश्न पर का यह वह
करें तो हम देखते हैं तो यह को आई लाइक
टीम बटाए प्रिंट कॉपी अलाइव टाइपिंग कॉफी
इसको हम थोड़ा सा इमोशन के साथ बोल सकते
हैं ऑइल दो आईटी वाटरिंग कॉपी ई
है तो यह जो चमन में ओम बना सकते हैं सवार
मां विश ते
कि आप पर स्प्रिंग कर काफी अधिक उत्पाद के
बाद मां क्यों आया चार पहले सेंटेंस का
पार्ट बन इसीलिए फार्माशिष्ट ते आप पर इस
ट्रिक को काव्य अपना ऑकुलर हमने पहले
सिकंदर मंदिर ऑपरेशन है वह कुछ सेंटेंस को
नहीं करता क्लियर है वैसे ही ऑल तो आई
लाइक क्रिकेट बट आप लेफ्ट बाल संवार मालिश
क्रिकेट आवर इश्क लुट बाल एकदम सिंपल
रहेगी और लास्ट कंज्यूम ज्यादा यूज नहीं
करने के लिए अपडेट में कबूल थे एक तरफ तो
यह है दूसरी तरफ है और वन हैंड अंदर हैं
परंतु कंप्लीट द कंसेप्ट हम वह भी सीख
लेते हैं और वन हैंड और इस फैसला व गुड
अंदर है डिटेल्स को अश्लील एक तरफ तो
टेस्ला अच्छी है पर दूसरी तरफ को महंगी है
तो वह कैसे का या आई न गए इस क्योंकि वह
सेकंड पोजीशन आएगा टेस्ला ग्रुप के अंदर
चैट स्टार्ट पर एकदम सिंपल है राइट कुछ भी
हाथ नहीं पड़ेगी
पैसे नहीं बोलते हैं जाऊंगा तो उसके सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट है देखो अगर आप देखोगे तो पहले
तीन एकदम सिंपल आप अपने नॉर्मल सेंटेंसेस
में यूज कर सकते हो कि अगर उसकी जगह
इंटर्व्यूअर वर्जन है तो हमने कंसेप्ट सी
इसलिए जहां दिखे वहां पर वह यूज करते मत
जाओ मतलब अगर एक पैर आप यह ऐसे में 2019
मत करो कि मैं चाय और कॉफी पीता हूं अब
हमेशा से ना सिर्फ चाय पत्ती भी डे अगर
वहां पर जरूरत है तो सब्सक्राइब करें
बोलते हो ना सिर्फ चाय-कॉफी भी पिता तो यह
ढंग से ऑल
क्वाइट एक्टिव वाटरिंग कॉफी इसमें और
इमोशन समझ लो मत सोएं यस द कंसेप्ट इस
वेरी इजी अगर आप देखोगे तो आज हमने क्या
देखा सिर्फ 10 न अवॉर्ड देखकर 5 पर ऑफ
वर्ड्स और सिर्फ द्वार अंदर साइड अंदर
प्लेटफॉर्म ने देखा कि वह सेंटेंस का
पार्ट बनते हैं और हमको इतने कंपलेक्स
सेंटेंस बनाने आ गए तो विंडो आफ हाउ टू डू
दिस इज वेरी सिंपल बट जैसे मैंने बोला हर
जगह नहीं यूज करना यस जहां पर उसकी जरूरत
हो वहां पर यूज करना पड़े सेट इस अ
very-very इंपोर्टेंट एंड वेरी वेरी इजी
कंसेप्ट मुझे आशा है कि आप सब लोगों को यह
कैंसर पसंद आई होगी हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
एपिसोड में धन्यवाद